as president biden pulling a bait and
switch he pitched himself as a centrist
but so far biden's policies are more in
line with the progressive left
the president continuing his record pace
of signing executive orders and actions
using his pen
again today for sweeping health care
changes so far
he's signed 40. that's on top of what
biden did yesterday on climate change
that has republicans
and workers furious the white house
touting future green energy jobs while
downplaying the impact it will have
on the fossil fuel industry gop
lawmakers saying it amounts to a war
on american workers they're disingenuous
i mean joe biden doesn't care about your
job he doesn't care about the people
that
that need to get back to work i mean he
has
he's he's a puppet for the radical left
and biden even facing a little backlash
from the new york times
an op-ed saying he's up on the executive
actions joe
and encourages him to get congress to
pass legislation i mean come on man um
jesse uh three of the
president's nominees in their
confirmation hearings they were asked
about
uh this issue about jobs and green jobs
uh pete budage once the transportation
secretary said
they'll just get new jobs michelle
grantham
she used the phrase they will sacrifice
jobs right maybe huge unforced errors
and john kerry said let them make solar
panels which is
pretty much like an olympic tone deaf
moment
uh i thought that was a good list for
you i didn't preview it as a list but
i'll turn it over to you for a comment
oh i have a list i i think mayor pete
should get a new job but that's besides
the point
i went back and researched what happened
to those obama green jobs
here's a list dana green jobs success
eludes obama politico
president obama's green job mirage
forbes
obama's green jobs have been slow to
sprout reuters
and the 5 million green jobs that
weren't
bloomberg so the very media that's
praising all these green job
promises from joe wrote about how the
green jobs never existed
under barack obama and then joe comes in
there and and
takes out the two biggest infrastructure
projects of the 21st century keystone
and the border wall and they're saying
it's going to cost
10 000 jobs the keystone the democrats
say oh
oh no those 10 thousand jobs they're
just temporary
well how long do you think dems does it
take to build a
continental pipeline it doesn't take a
week it takes years
so those were ten thousand jobs were
going to be there for years
and they say oh yeah you can go build a
solar panel do you know the average
salary of someone that works as a
petroleum engineer
it's 137 000 you don't make that
building solar panels
yeah the reason why emissions have been
going down
over the last what since 2006 we're
actually at the
1990 levels right now is natural gas
it's not
solar and wind it's clean and it keeps
us out of the mess in the middle east
and it undercuts the russian energy
politics so i don't know why they don't
get on board with gas
get on board with gas juan stay on the
ground come on man
come on man juan um to that point that
jesse just brought up though
with the media that were assessed the
green energy jobs in the obama
administration
um it's only been four years um i don't
think that the biden team has shown that
there's been a lot of change
and innovation since then especially in
this past year with the pandemic
there's been some but not enough to get
everyone a new job
well i think there has been change first
in terms of the
uh climate change and what we know about
and its impact on
us as the american people and on the
globe but secondly i think that you've
seen more innovation we just heard today
gm said they're going to stop making gas
powered cars in the next 15 years
and that you get a sense of how you know
i think was 150 ceos of the big
companies dana said
they're all for this new agenda in terms
of
going forward with energy innovation
keeping us ahead
right now there are more jobs more jobs
in terms of
solar power wind power than there are in
the in the
coal industry so why wouldn't we want
government to support
that burgeoning industry as it competes
with the chinese and the germans
we should want them to be at the
forefront that's the idea
and i mean look the other thing that he
signed today was about
medicare getting more people into
medicare opening the insurance markets
for a country in the middle of a
pandemic this is good news we should
also be saluting him for this
greg are we saluting i am not saluting
uh i i keep hearing about these
these tons of solar-powered solar panel
making jobs
are they in america i'm just wondering
what is the american company that you
know of offhand that make solar panels
because i can't think of one offhand i
think they might be mostly made in china
where everything is cheaply made so i i
actually salute you juwan for paying for
the flights
or renting uh john kerry's private jet
to fly all the coal miners
out of pennsylvania where they can go
and work in china they'll have to leave
their families behind
and they'll probably have to move in
with the uyghurs and that's just the way
it's going to go
look america was fed a big lie they
thought they were getting a comfy
cardigan
instead they got a hair shirt designed
by antifa you know we
if you couldn't see joe biden you
wouldn't know he's an 80 year old white
male
he'd be you'd think he was a gender
studies major from brown
it's like every there's every decision
is extreme
and what's missing is any semblance of
thoughtfulness or
wisdom and the thing about great the
great thing about elderly people
wisdom comes standard it comes with time
if you're on the planet that long
it kind of naturally comes out of your
pores we somehow were able to elect the
only 80 year old man
who has no wisdom and look 40 executive
orders
i totally understand why biden would do
40 executive orders given that he
doesn't have the house or senate
oh wait wait wait so he doesn't actually
have to do this i'd say that joe is
running the country by fiat
but it's more like a studebaker ah gosh
i knew you were going to do that i was
like fiat i heard it
katie even the new york times was like
please we can't take it we can't take
all the executive orders
yeah you know it's interesting to watch
the white house press secretary today
talk about how american families are
struggling they need government checks
they need to put food on the table
they're having a hard time
and yet the president just with a pen
destroyed thousands of high-paying jobs
but the other thing dana that the
president signed today
was reinstituting taxpayer funding for
abortions
overseas and again biden said that he
was a moderate that's what he ran on but
a new marist poll this week showed that
55 percent of democrats
and 85 percent of independents do not
support
taxpayer funding for abortion overseas
so again
extreme executive orders coming out of
an oval office that was supposed to be
pretty moderate
all right good talk everybody